hi my name is ryan carter and today i'll
be presenting on
why my security camera screams like a
banshee just talking on
signal analysis and reverse engineering
of an audio encoding protocol
a little bit about myself i'm a software
developer a security engineer
i love to code love to automate love to
solve
problems i like to employ the hacker
mindset
i like to break things into in cool and
unexpected ways
to learn more about the system and
hopefully drive a driving improvement
that makes it better for everybody
i love food love i love cooking love
baking
recipe hacking is a passion of mine and
when i can get a delicious result
you know it really makes my day and then
of course the standard disclaimer
applies here
all opinions are my own don't reflect
the positions or thoughts of
anybody else or any current or previous
employer so
let's get to it i've got a few different
uh
sections to cover we're going to touch
on what it is that we're actually doing
here
the signal analysis piece application
analysis
hacking the signal and if all goes well
we'll uh we'll get to a demo
so what are we doing here and uh why are
we talking about
wireless security cameras so
my original goal you know before i even
had the idea to uh to submit a defcon
talk was to use an inexpensive wireless
camera to monitor my my garden
and uh this is the inexpensive camera i
selected
um you know it's got an antenna suitable
for outdoor use
um this one's kind of interesting that
it has a as a microphone and a speaker
so you could have a
two-way communication if if you wanted
it uh the nice thing about this is that
it was a it was cheap
so and it seemed like it would do the
job
this sounds fairly easy and
straightforward so uh
what's the catch here i discovered after
purchasing the camera unboxing it and
examining it that
it requires a uh a cloud application in
order to
enable and uh and pair the camera
this um there's there's no way to self
set up the camera
there's no uh ad hoc wireless network uh
it doesn't show up as a as with a
bluetooth connection
there's that when you plug in the usb
cable there's uh there's no signals
there whatsoever
also there's no documentation online
about this about this camera to any real
technical depth
uh not that i was expecting much from uh
from a 30 camera
then of course um what brings us here
today
is the bespoke protocol that it uses to
that well that the vendor application
uses to communicate and configure
the the wireless camera so
take a take a listen to to this this is
what really piqued my
interest and sent me down the path of
trying to do a defcon defcon
presentation
[Music]
so that's the sound that the uh that
this
vendor application makes um to interface
with the camera
and configure it to uh to connect to a
wireless
wireless network uh i i have to say i
was not expecting that
that's uh that's not not usually how you
configure things like
like security cameras so my new goal
after um after finding out that it uses
a sound wave signal to
to configure the camera is to was to
find out what was going on during the
camera setup
and see if i can't hack on it and
replicate it and
if possible cast off the shackles of the
uh of the proprietary
cloud enabled uh you know app that the
vendor supplies
so let's let's investigate first thing
you want to investigate is is the
hardware
and as i mentioned before you know it
does have a usb
cable this connector though only
supplies
power when i trace the leads there's no
uh no activity on the on the data pins
other investigative angles of course you
know check for for bluetooth check for
ad hoc wi-fi
um and unfortunately
after many hours of trying all sorts of
different permutations
of uh of things pressing the reset
button holding the reset button
you know scanning with wireless scanners
etc nothing nothing was advertising
so that leaves uh that left me to
investigate the the software in a little
bit more more detail
this is the vendor application that
comes with the camera it's called
jawa and it's used to configure
the cloud camera however you know like i
mentioned before i'm not really
i wasn't really a fan of having to use
this this proprietary cloud locked
application
uh java requires an internet connection
it also requires a username and password
to be
configured with um with this this cloud
set up so that that made me maybe a
little frustrated
and incentivized me to uh to poke around
some more
now in order to analyze the vendor
application
i um you know i needed a test device i
didn't want to run this on my
my primary phone just being a the
security paranoid person that i am
i don't really have a trust for um uh
for applications that come from from
dubious sources like the manufacturer of
a 30
cloud enabled camera and
as i searched online for information
either about the the camera or the
application
uh you know probably not too surprising
to hear that there wasn't very many
if any results that uh that were that
were found
i i did uncover a few other camera
models that seemed to use
the sound audio wave signal approach to
configure the camera for wi-fi network i
i don't have any of those though and i
just more list them here as
an interesting interesting aside
there are some cheap cameras though
which leverage uh in my opinion a far
superior approach to uh
pairing the camera to a wireless network
and that's having it
having the app show a qr code that you
then
scan with the uh with the camera i mean
the camera has
well a camera and scanning a qr code is
a fairly straightforward piece of uh
you know it's a fairly straightforward
thing to do in 2021 so
i i doubt or i should say i wonder if
there'll be many if any more cameras out
there which
which leverage this audio uh audio coded
approach
so now that we've taken a quick pass
that the hardware and the software
let's let's think about this signal a
little bit more see what we can
see what we can identify and figure out
and along the way let's think about what
are some things that we can
we can think about or look for as we
analyze this signal
of course the first thing is we'll want
to capture and visualize the signal
uh we'll be looking for things like
repetition that variation in replay
um you know and if possible we'll try to
fuzz and simulate the signal in a way
that
can uh i can hopefully track with uh
with a valid relevant coding
this is the uh the raw view of the
signal is captured in
as captured by audacity and visualized
in the
spectrographic view just uh just taking
a quick look at this
it's uh it's pretty clear that there are
there are distinct tones
and um it appears to be there appears to
be steps this isn't a continuous
waveform
that uh that gets transmitted there's
individual tones
which are given certain slices of time
you know
that are transmitted for a certain
amount of time and then other tones are
played after that
uh taking a look uh it seems like a lot
of the signals are centering at least
here
around 3 500 hertz uh with a few
outliers on
on the low end of the range frequency
range and
and the high end is as well so this that
is something worth
worth noting as we go about analyzing
the signal
now let's see
one thing that i thought as i was um you
know looking at the signal is
is this similar to um to a modem signal
it's been an awful long time since i've
uh heard
a modem and obviously
obviously modems encode their uh you
know
transmit information using using an
audio signal so
we did i did a quick comparison against
a recording of 56k
dial up modem establishing a connection
and just by looking at um at these
waveforms
it's it's pretty apparent that it's
it's not a 56k k modem the the
spectrographs are substantially
different
and this this protocol this audio
protocol that they're using to configure
the camera is
uh you know it's bespoke in the sense
that it's uh
not you can't find information about it
easily and it doesn't track with
you know other common audio protocols
that you might think of like uh modem or
facts
so looking a little closer at this with
it with our eyes
we can uh we you know i marked out a few
sections that that appeared interesting
just really highlighting the um the
signals that appear
that that are extraneous or um that
don't really track with what the rest of
the signal
offers and on the left of the
of this slide here i uh i put together i
guess what i'm calling a collapsed
spectrograph view
where i basically took all of the tones
and i slid them
all over all over to my left and i just
lined them up to see which which tones
and frequencies were represented
and you can see that um you know that it
does center around a 3 500 hertz
there's a small gap above above 4 4
000 hertz and then there appear to be
some things at the at the higher
end at the higher register range
now a picture is is nice and it helps us
understand maybe how the how the signal
is structured
yeah but a picture can only take us so
far we'd like to get more precise
and better understand what is actually
encoded in this
signal and um how
the uh and kind of what the protocol is
for actually encoding data into the
signal
with that with a manual approach um you
know we can keep using a tool
such as audacity or or other audio
editing tools
that are out there with audacity though
i
you can use this um functionality called
labeling
you position the cursor over each one of
those um
you know sections where there appears to
be a distinct tone
you press ctrl b and it will cause
audacity to uh
to label that time slice and mark
the the frequency that's detected at
that at that point in time
and so you can see just in the signal in
this picture here
it might be a little smaller a little
hard to see but i've got a bunch
of labels on each one of these tones
this next view here is the audacity view
where you can
view the labels that that you've that
you've taken
you can go to you know edit labels edit
labels and
you can export them to a text file which
you know you could run through some
other type of automated analysis or
plug it into a spreadsheet or or what
have you
let's take a little closer look at this
and you can see that um audacity is
mapping a low and a high frequency
that it detects at that time slice
the these frequencies are a little
variable so
to me it looks like this this puts us in
in the ballpark
for what each of the um target tones are
i don't imagine the uh the application
the vendor application is really
putting out 5101.89 hertz it's probably
something a bit more
bit more round you know but we'll figure
figure out more about that as as we go
along in this process
what uh what do we know now from doing
our quick manual analysis
uh we can see that there's uh there is
encoding going on uh there's there's a
digitized
signal but the signal isn't isn't binary
it's not like it's just
two tones one and zero there's there's a
range of frequencies
represented here so there's some type of
digital encoding going on
um that the frequencies seem to be
centered in the three to five kilohertz
range and um you know my suspicion is
that uh the signals that are
outliers at the top and bottom are are
control signals
and that they they want a closer look
for investigating how a signal
how the signal is put together and we
see that there's repetition
i noticed that um in my analysis of the
vendor application and the uh
and the pairing tones that it that it
produces the complete sequence
uh repeats itself multiple times at
least three times
so and then finally we can see that this
is not a 56k modem
or a fax uh effect signal the spectral
analyses just
just do not match
so at this point uh we have to ask
ourselves
is there really much further that we can
go in manual mode
and the answer there is yes but with
with a set of caveats
there is variability whenever you play
back the audio signal
i found that each time i played back
even the same signal
from the vendor application that
audacity would
would slightly vary that the audacity
analysis would slightly vary in terms of
which frequencies it uh you know it
shows when you do the labeling process
and of course manually going through the
process of playing a signal from uh from
an application recording it into
an audio editor and doing that over and
over again
it's very time consuming since um again
the app repeats the same signal multiple
times
so even after you get a complete signal
captured you have to wait for the app to
finish its full cycle before you can
kick off
another test permutation and uh you know
just to be clear the only options we
have to configure in this vendor
application are
you know the the ssid and like and the
passphrase for the wireless network
so there's not a whole lot of things
that you can you can vary for the input
then um one thing i noticed is that
there's no readily apparent api
um to you know to leverage the uh the
frequency detection
portion of audacity there's no cli
option there's no
readily available api option and while i
could have dug deeper into the audacity
code base to um
you know better understand how that's
put together and hook into it
that really wasn't what uh wasn't what i
was trying to go for that doesn't really
that's more that would be more of an
aside as opposed to helping me on my
main journey to
reverse engineer and better understand
this uh this audio signal
so you know with manual mode we can do
black box signal reversing we can try to
brute force reproduce the tones
we can attempt to match generated tones
with spectrographic views
and then of course just um you know
fuzzing generating permutations until we
until we find a match
this is a very tedious and a
time-consuming process though so i was
looking for a better way
to leverage what i have and what i know
in order to improve this process
so really the next next step here is to
do
an analysis of the android application
since um the android application is what
generates the audio signals
and uh let's take a closer look at this
vendor application
so how do we go about um
analysis of a of an artifact of a
software artifact
uh we could do things like um executing
it and logging the results in a sandbox
or a test environment
we can uh decompile the the package
uh we can look for strings you know that
anything that might relate to audio or
sound or um you know ssids and passwords
things of that nature
we can do a key method search since um
this is a
android uses a higher level language or
at least i should say
this uh this apk is written to uh
you know to a higher level language and
even though vendors can obfuscate their
code
it's it's a lot harder to obfuscate the
underlying library functions that that
you use as a vendor
so you can do thing you could do a
search for um you know android system
calls or android libraries that provide
methods that
you might need when dealing with audio
and audio encoding
uh you know once we figure out these
code paths we can attempt to do high
speed fuzzing
and then of course if we if we identify
something that has been obfuscated
we can uh we can try to go and
de-obfuscate it
and attribute uh the classes the methods
the properties
some other identifiers which makes more
sense to humans and
uh helps us better reason about the code
to uh you know
to really figure out how this all works
now let's talk a little bit about
preparation
you'll need to you know prepare your
computer to uh pull the apk off of your
test device
um you know if you've done any of this
if you've worked with android before
you've
you're probably already familiar with
this and you need to make sure your
developer mode is enabled that you've
allowed usb debugging make sure that you
have android studio installed and that
version of adb is correctly
placed in your path so that way you can
leverage it for the for the purposes of
this
you'll want to extract the the android
package
you know and here i i show a few
commands that you can use if you want to
you know follow along afterwards uh and
try this you'll want to make sure that
you um take the output of each step
and feed it into the next step since um
what i have here
is really only applicable to um a uh
a blackberry priv because this is the
the test device that i had lying around
after all these years to uh to do this
analysis on
once you have the apk you can use a tool
to decompile it
i leveraged a jx you can go to the
github
page pull the latest release and then
it's a it's very simple to
to decompile the code just a quick
one-liner
you you will probably note that um it'll
show finished with errors
i found that the errors did not
negatively impact my analysis of the
package
and i was not impeded in my in my
journey
once you're in once you have the
decompiled sources you'll want to open
up a new android studio project
um you know open the decompiled sources
from from jet x and then click a little
button in the lower right hand corner
that says configure the android
framework
by configuring the android framework um
it enables you to do things like um
find usages and um go to definition
just um all the goodness that you'd
expect from a from a modern ide
once it's loaded you'll see a bunch of
classes um on the side
you know this the one that i have
highlighted there is uh u dot aly
which is uh clearly clearly obfuscated
as you drill into there there's
there's a bunch of obfuscated classes
and methods
now a quick note an obfuscated code
what is obfuscation sometimes software
makers want to hide
their their implementations and they
want to
impede you from figuring out how it how
they work
and uh you know from reverse engineering
to better understand
what the um you know what the underlying
mechanisms of its of its operation are
uh with with higher level languages you
get uh terse randomly generated
identifiers you know you might have a
class named
lowercase a you might have a method
named
you know f999 or just whatever the case
case may be
it's harder to obfuscate the use of
system libraries in
a higher level language since um you
know those uh those decompile cleanly
back to uh back to base libraries so
uh why do we use android studio or i
should say what what's the advantage
of using android studio is in your
manual the obfuscation process
um you know it's it's a very slick ide
it's free it's readily available
you know it receives a lot of a lot of
support a lot of people use it
and then of course you get all the all
the classic ide functionality like
find usages go to declarations um
things like that with android in
particular you get a log cat
instance or a long cat window which lets
you search
you can also target specific
applications that are running on a phone
to
reduce the verbosity of the messages
that
that you see and better help you tailor
your analysis
let's take a look at what we can do with
this application
so live log analysis uh
you know this is one of the first things
i tried because
being a developer myself i know that
oftentimes the debug logs will contain a
wealth of information
and as a regular user of the of the
phone or the service or the application
a regular user is not going to see the
debug output
so if you're rushing a release out the
door um
and you don't disable your debug output
you know somebody like me is going to
come along
and hook up the device hook up the
android phone
to uh to logcat and investigate for for
messages if you're curious about what's
going on
now let's take a look at what
logs we get as we as we start this
application
here's the login screen um
here's a little capture from uh from
logcat
we can see that there's there's some
interesting information uh in there
there appears to be
some kind of an encoded payload there's
um
some interesting strings in there and we
we appear to be getting both
you know informational and debug output
so you know there's there's a url the
ap.javalife.net you know
go jawas and then as we as we kind of
continue scrolling through the screen
there's a lot more messages um like this
when you uh try the camera pairing
process
you have to enter in the ssid and the
password
and um at this stage we see that
this log output which logs the the ssid
the password and then what appears to be
some kind of a randomly generated token
and uh in this log output i know it's
really hard to see here
but there's a there's a class that we
can start to investigate
and then there's a what appears to be an
http helper class which is um
what helps us send and receive messages
back from the the cloud
cloud server let's uh
try to pair to a camera and and see what
we get
so there's a button that says click to
send the sound wave
just uh love it it makes me smile when i
when i see that
and uh when we send the sound wave we uh
we get some additional information and
it may not look like
much but um there are a few strings here
which
which can help help in the analysis
we found um you know just to recap what
we found so far
we found a distinctive characters we
found urls we found a class to
investigate this a bind
device new activity that sounds
particularly fitting given that we are
trying to
enable and configure a new a new camera
device
so where does this lead us
we can continue our search by taking
those strings that we found in the log
output and
searching for them within android studio
and
uh as as i searched through the uh the
decompiled output
i found found a few things it looks like
um the
the number one is used to delimit fields
they they call the random generated code
they call it a smart code
then uh there's a character sorry a
string
one that's appended at the end of this
little message block and um you know
even though
android studio is calling this message
db notify reached
i kind of wonder if this isn't a
decompilation artifact of some kind
because it really is just uh
just the string of the character one
so what is this smart code thing i
noticed that each time i tried to pair
via the camera to the to the cloud app
this smart code would
would change it it would be different
every time
and i could see by looking at this um at
this boot up code
that yes every time that that you
attempt to pair the camera
you uh get characters and numbers for
six characters
and that constitutes the uh smart code
but the question still remains like what
is this thing
and just after having gone through this
this entire analysis process
and seen it seen it change with
every single time that i attempt to pair
and noticing that
whenever i paired the camera a message
was sent
from the from the application up to the
cloud server
that included the random code i can only
presume
that the backend cloud service uses this
random code
to tie this camera to my
user account in the in the cloud since
um
you know it's uh that how else is the
the camera going to identify that it uh
you know
belongs to my to my account so that
that's the best guess that i have for
what this what this code is
is used for um as we continue
looking through the the strings we can
see um other strings which
guide us to processes sorry to functions
methods
that uh that weren't for their
investigation like run and play voice
both of those sound you know they sound
good
let's uh let's take a closer look and uh
do an extractive analysis at this point
we've um we've uncovered a lot of uh
you know a lot of a lot of functions a
lot of methods um
uh static you know constants
in in the code base and uh we want to
take
you know the key sections out of the
vendor application
put them in a clean project so that way
we can we can perform an analysis
just a couple of notes on on setting up
the um
the the clean application if the
you know if you're looking at another
application which like this application
here
leverages native libraries you'll need
to manually create a jni libs folder
put all those compiled libraries into
the jni libs directory
and then you'll need to have make that
make the java class
that matches
the package structure has to be the same
so uh this thing is called like com.i
think.voice
in the vendor application i can't call
it um
com.test.reverse engineer i have to name
the package structure the same
because um the way that jni works it um
it requires those two things to
to match up and once you have your your
uh
sample test project set up you're able
to perform a
black box analysis of the uh of you know
of the code that's used to generate the
signal
and along this way uh one of the
questions that i that i had
was well what are the exact tones that
are being generated
by the application to um to pair and
bind with
with the camera well there's a there's a
class called v code table
and um as i ran it in this extracted
project
it produced a mapping of all of the uh
the tones
all the tones is along with the um
you know the characters that they map to
so this is what the characters map
to uh we have from zero to 48.75 hertz
um and it's there are 16 16 states so
this is a
a hexadecimal you know style style and
coding care
now looking at what else we found here
there's a lot of findings we know that
android uses
audio track to we know that the
application uses audio track to play a
signal
and we've identified how it uh creates
the payload as far as you know the ssid
the the password uh the random code and
then the delimiters between those fields
we've identified control tones like the
frequency begin and frequency ends that
are that are just static constants
there's also a space tone which you know
is used for
when two tones play back to back the
same tone
there's a little space tone that that
pops in
and that'll be better visualized um in a
later slide
there's methods which play the
characters there's the use of the crc
values to um
help the camera know if it's received a
complete signal or not so uh there's a
been a wealth of information that we've
uncovered through this this process
so what do we know now we can
reconstruct
all of section one and section two of
the signal
because that each signal consists of a
of three sections
and um you know now that we can
reconstruct section one and section two
uh really that just leaves at least
section three
and um i've highlighted in this image
the uh part of the code which is
sorry the part of the signal which is is
elusive at this stage in the
analysis this this tone appears to be
some type of error correction code
it doesn't exactly track with the the
crc process that the rest of the code
base
uses though which uh which left me
wondering
and since this is generated by my code
that's in
a native library it means that i need
binary analysis to
to dig deeper and try to figure out
what's going on here
my tool of choices is jidra hedra i
don't know how to pronounce that
it's uh it's a free tool it's it's very
capable and it
does the job here so to get set up with
gtram
you'll want to visit their their github
page pull the latest release for your
platform and then uh follow the
follow the installation guide once you
have
judo installed create a new project um
you know fill out all the wizard boxes i
just i just took basically all
the defaults and give it a project name
click the dragon
icon import the the native library that
you want to analyze
in my case i just went with the x86 64
library since
i'm a little bit more comfortable with
x86 than i am with uh
with arm libraries at the moment when
you click
the yes button it'll go through and
it'll do an analysis of
of this compiled library which you can
then um navigate in the ui
so reverse engineering with g-drab
we need to know what we're looking at
here so you want to go to your android
studio project
make sure that you identify which
functions
which methods are which methods
in the higher level language map two
functions in the compiled library
once you know that you can look in the
in the symbol tree
and you can see here that there's a
number of a java
java com interops so jni interfaces here
in this native library
the uh the methods that we're looking
for are the get voice structures that
are listed towards
the bottom of the screen and here's a
closer view on what you would see
in indirect as you do this analysis
so now we just need to pick one of the
functions and dig in
i focused on this intuitively named
function called get
voice struct goki2 so i love the
spelling of voice and i don't know what
goki2 means this is the function though
that generates the
the section 2 and section 3 output 4 for
the audio signal
one thing that i noticed as i was doing
this analysis
is that on the java side you pass in
eight parameters to this native function
yet on the on the compiled side when we
look at this function at the function
signature in gendra
there are 10 parameters here so
um you know it's it seems a little odd
but then uh
doing a little bit of reading i found
that jni calling conventions add
add two parameters there's a um
uh yeah let's talk about the note on jni
there's there's a jni environment
pointer and then there's
an object pointer and these two
parameters are front loaded to the to
the function
signature so those first two are just um
the environment
and and the object so i've uh
this top picture is the uh the raw
decompiled view
just um with all the the generated
identifiers that don't really make a lot
of sense
the uh the bottom picture shows that
refactored in in g-dram
to uh that to indicate that the first
two parameters are you know are j and i
related
now let's continue the analysis okay
so inside of jitra there's a function d
compiler window
and um the nice thing about g drive it's
it's like uh
it's like most other ides that i've
worked with you can right click on an
identifier
you can rename it you can highlight it
you know you can do things that will
help you analyze the the flow
of how a particular parameter is used
and manipulated
so this function you know this uh
uh get voice struct to go q
it calls of calls another function that
leverages the inputs that are that are
passed into this this function
uh what i do when i do this type of
analysis is for each screen that i'm
that i'm on
i try to do try to rename and refactor
the parameters
and the methods the functions to names
that actually make some
some degree of human sense so that's
what i'll be doing here
this is the the cleaned up view and um i
know it's small
but the picture shows that each of those
parameters
are named to reflect what value they
represent from the um
you know from the android side and then
you know i go from there
i check the usages since this is
decompiled
you know there's there can be a lot of
uh well sometimes it doesn't exactly
make the most sense you like i noticed
that uh
input parameters are copied to local
variables
and then those local variables are then
used elsewhere so
in the analysis just uh keep in mind
what you're looking at
track the flow through the local you
know through any type of intermediate
steps that it goes through to see where
it winds up being manipulated
now this is the uh this is the raw view
of that um of that nested function
fortunately for me and almost
conveniently so for this demo
this is a very small function there's
only it's only about
58 yeah i'm actually about 56 lines long
so it makes it pretty easy to uh to
analyze
uh you know again since the the
identifiers are all terse and auto
generated
i need to refactor those into something
that i can use
so start with what you know find a good
starting point
even if you can't get all the names to
something human readable
just to do what you know and as you
reason through the code
you'll find that um it uh you know the
rest of the pieces can fall into place
sometimes if you enter what you know
as i went through this and did all the
renaming i
found that the critical the critical
section the critical operation that i
needed to apply
in my you know uh reverse engineering
project
to replicate the signal three it just
came down to
uh a shift so this is the line
um it takes the uh the crc'd ssid
and then it shifts it uh to the right
so that that's a very simple operation
for me to perform
in my replicated android project it is
not something that i was able to figure
out just by reasoning through the java
or by passing in inputs to the library
function and fuzzing the output
i think probably with enough time i
probably would have figured it out
but you know just i get a little
impatient
and when i can go explore a little
deeper and uh more fully understand how
something works i'll take that
opportunity
so a shift that's all i got to do to
replicate section 3.
now let's think about um hacking the
signal how can we recreate this
and manipulate it to to serve our
purposes
so let's look again at what we know this
is the spectrographic waveform
of of a complete pairing cycle
the waveform is comprised of three
sections of a
hexified data each section is prefixed
and suffixed by control codes and
section identifiers
uh we know that when two sequential
tones
are uh are used there's a space tone
that shows up in between it
to help the camera better differentiate
and identify
you know distinct signals the duration
of each tone that i found is about 50 to
60 milliseconds
and we know the structure of each
waveform section
let's look at section one this is uh
this one's a long one
it's got frequency begin it's got um
delimited ssid passphrase and
random code digits it has a crcs
of of a bunch of data put together and
then it's got into tones
section two is um incredibly simple by
comparison
all it's about is um it's the smart code
and just making sure that um there's a
proper error correction on that
that randomly generated code so that's
that's a very
terse very short very easy to reason
through section three
yeah this one's a little bit longer as
well we have some
crc codes in there uh we have another
kind of like a mutilated version of the
smart
code there's a the passphrase bytes
another crc and then
this thing wraps up so we can reproduce
the signal now we know
um every aspect of every part of the
signal
and we are able to to recreate it as a
result
so that's where the uh the demo comes
into play here
i created an application which
can be used to pair these uh
pair this wireless camera to a wireless
network
without having to use the the cloud
application
this enables the camera to be further
analyzed using more traditional
um you know but network uh network style
investigation techniques
so with that let's go ahead and
let's uh take a look at the demo
in this demo we'll be pairing
the wireless camera with
a wireless network that's hosted on this
laptop running host apd advertising a
defcon 29
ssid to do the pairing
we will leverage the uh the reverse
engineered application
that that i created as part of this
kind of reverse engineering process
where i've configured the ssid and
passphrase now
to get this camera to pair we need to
wait for it to get into
setup mode um after i plug it in
we'll want to wait for the flashing
light
and at that point the camera should be
um susceptible to our
suggestion that it paired to a specific
network so
i'll plug the camera into the power bank
and start it up
on boot the camera shows a solid green
light
to indicate that it has power
after it goes through its setup sequence
and you know whatever that entails i
can't
haven't been able to really probe that
it'll go into a flashing light mode
where we can pass it along our message
so let's give this a try
all right with that tone
it should indicate that the camera has
received
our um our pairing
message and in the
wireshark capture
you will see that um
the camera is communicating with with
the network
and um that it's that it's paired so
that is looking good
let's take another look at the uh
pairing
this time from the screen recording that
shows the
wire shark output of our packet capture
as the camera goes through its
initialization sequence
and receives our pairing code it should
show up requesting an address which in
this case i've
targeted to be a specific one in advance
you can see here that uh it receives an
ip address on the local
demo network and
it proceeds to query back home
and attempt to uh
you know attempt to call home and do the
cloud
cloud configuration bit
we're going to try connecting to the
cameras video now one thing i do want to
note about this camera is that the
the video connection can be a little bit
iffy
it doesn't always work
and can require three four uh you know
sometimes upwards five
different attempts to get the video
signal to work
here i'm showing an attempt to connect
to the camera using vlc
and surprise surprise it
uh it fires right up so go figure
let's go ahead and wrap this up now
there are a few limitations that are
worth noting
it's not easy to discover the device's
administrative password it is
six hexadecimal characters
and the password changes each time the
camera is reset
it doesn't seem to be tied to mac or
serial number so just uh
kind of brute forcing your way through
it might be
one no one decent option the easiest
option is just to have it pair once to
the
cloud and pull the
password off of that that is not
not the approach that i would prefer if
at all possible though
so it's not possible
or not really very easy i should say to
decipher the camera to cloud
communication
based off of some of the code that i've
seen in the application and
what i've intercepted between the camera
and the
the cloud servers the the camera has a
local rsa key pair that changes on
on reset or potentially between each
request
the payloads are encrypted
and sent over to the server so even
though you can
view the payloads by setting up a
self-signed demand in the middle
server you can't really make sense of
what the payloads are
saying so it could be worth some
additional investigation you also
get what you pay for even if you know
the password it doesn't always connect
vlc will sometimes connect and sometimes
it will not
so just uh keep that in mind if you want
to
economize and save a bucket you want to
on a cheap wireless camera
so thank you very much for attending my
defcon talk
it's uh it's been a real pleasure to
spend this time with you today
so thanks